crisper these days refers to the suite
of technologies that can edit the DNA of
living cells by adding removing or
changing segments of it cancer by
definition is a genetic disease caused
by DNA mutations changes within the
sequences of DNA so can we cure cancer
with crisper that is the hope of many
researchers but a current promising
solution that we'll take a look at in
this video is perhaps not the
straightforward solution you we're
thinking of let's
investigate cancer is a disease that
occurs when some cells in the body start
to grow out of control and inade other
tissues or organs cancer is caused by
changes in the DNA of these cells which
can be inherited or acquired during
one's lifetime so if we have a tool like
crisper surely it would just make sense
to use it and fix the DNA
changes well while this could be a
possibility for some cancers for many
well it's not that simple cancer is a
complex and multifaceted disease there
are different types of cancers caused by
different mutations with resistance to
different drugs and therapies and
Cancers themselves are very
heterogeneous with different cancer
cells having different mutational
profiles so for sure you could take a
cell from a tumor sequence its DNA try
to find the mutations and then develop a
crisper that could edit all of these
mutations but that's not a quick nor
simple nor cheap nor necessary even
effective strategy and even if you
wanted to create some therapy the tumor
might have mutated further within that
time period and the patient would only
further suffer plus no new drug can go
straight to a patient has to be tested
first in clinical trials so you would
have to give the same therapy to
everyone but not everyone has the same
tumor a lot of these tumors have
variations so in other words for sure
there is still some hope here but it's
not really a feasible approach but why
try and refer the cell that's become
mutated back to being non-mutated why
don't we just kill the cancer cell can
we use crisper for that well yes we
could but before we get to that we need
to consider how our bodies typically
respond to cancerous cells you see
cancer cells are mutated versions of
normal cells so typically this involves
the presence of mutated proteins found
within
cells our immune system is positioned to
detect foreign cells which while
typically means infected cells can also
mean cancer cells instead of FAL or
bacterial antigens being recognized by a
subset of the immune cells called te-
cells cancer antigens can instead be
recognized these antigens being the
mutated parts of the normal proteins as
to the te- cells these mutated parts of
the protein look
foreign however as immune mediated
selection is very potent as it kills the
cell it would be important for the tea
cells not to recognize healthy cells and
and so there are biological signaling
mechanisms that actually tend to
attenuate the tea cell response in other
words cancer cells can find ways to
persist if they AFF fade this immune
mediated clearance through other
mutations so what if we use crisper to
improve the potency of these immune
cells and redirect them towards cancer
cells well was an excellent idea but
firstly let's just recap what crisper is
crisper and crisper Associated proteins
are key components of an ancient
bacterial adaptive immune system
following its Discovery it's been
repurposed as Gene editing technology in
its Simplicity the components include an
RNA guiding part that locates a specific
region on DNA and the protein component
which has the activity to cut DNA so the
two components RNA and protein they go
together like Ram L
Lama then once they find the region of
DNA there's a snip by cast 9 and boom
double stranded break now this there I
say it traditional crisper cast 9 system
where it introduces a break and both
strands of DNA is actually quite
hazardous for a cell with double
stranded breaks being an initial cause
of cancer causing
mutations so researchers have found
alternative ways to edit DNA without
breaking both DNA strands one of these
methods is called Bas editing Bas
editing doesn't involve the crisper
protein cutting the D itself it's all
about that base that base no trouble
indeed because this time we switch out
the base directly by adding and editing
enzyme to the cine protein what we can
do with the editing is more limited here
but it's much safer okay so let's just
try and recap here what edits are we
actually making if we're not editing the
cancer cells directly well this is the
clever part instead of editing the
cancer cells that's a heterogeneous the
logic is to edit the immune cells and to
make make them super stealthy and
resilient to go and kill the cancer
cells directly these Gene edited types
of immune cells where they are directed
towards cancer cells are called car T
cells cars standing for chimeric antigen
receptors a receptor is added to the tea
cell so that they can detect the cancer
cells mimicking the way that our body
would naturally recognize foreign
cells however there are additional
changes that researchers are
investigating to make these car cells
even better as a therapeutic
because not that they have a botch
company but logically speaking a company
When developing a drug needs to
prioritize three main things firstly
that this drug is effective that it
kills the cancer
cells secondly that it does this safely
it doesn't cause some other disease and
thirdly to try to make it cost effective
hopefully such that it benefits the
patient not just the company's Bank
wallet so the way to do this is to also
edit the tea cells so that they are
resistant to signals that suppress their
activity and that the tea cells
themselves are not recognized as foreign
by the body it C thetive decision would
also be to generate allogeneic C T cells
meaning that any patient could get the
same supply of te- cells compared to
autologus where the cells would need to
be made for each patient anyhow a recent
preprint has used base editing and
crisper to make six Gene edits to make C
T cells these C T cells had improved
anti-tumor efficacy leading to improved
tumor elimination and survival in
humanized Mouse models here you can see
the tumor volume over time Post delivery
of the tea cells for mice that are
injected with human lung cancer
cells so even though car te- cells were
developed some 25 years ago we now have
the tools to make them superar te- cells
so crisper has and will continue to have
a massive potential for cancer
immunotherapy and this is what
mentioning that crisper is being used in
general to study cancer biology we can
use crisper to create cancer models in
different species such as mice to do
large scale screens to understand the
impact of mutations and identify novel
therapeutic targets as well as
alternative crisper proteins that could
be used for early cancer detection and
Diagnostics today I've only just
highlighted one potential Avenue that
seems promising so with that I hope
you've learned something in this video
thank you to my Patron supporters and
thank you for listening